this video is for those of you going to
Saudi Arabia or thinking of going to
Saudi Arabia an amazing two weeks in the
country and learned a lot and I wish I
had some of this information before I
went because it's really tough it's
really tough to find good information
about traveling in Saudi online and so
tourism just opened up
I believe the 27th of September 2019 and
before I went I was doing my research
and I saw this video in this video said
if you take photos or video in public
and get a car you'll receive I think was
like three months in prison and $150,000
fine and so since I was going to make a
video series there and guys I'll have
that in my link below I did an 11 part
video series on Saudi if you want to see
what it's like on the ground check it
out well since I was going for that that
wasn't the information I wanted to see
so I did my research talk to some people
on the ground found out that was BS
you're not gonna go to prison for taking
a photo or shooting video or pay a fine
so yeah things are changing a bit as far
as information online because more
vloggers are going more people are
telling their stories but there are some
things I wish I knew before I went and
so when you tell people hey mom or
whomever I'm going to Saudi Arabia most
likely they're not going to get excited
and they're gonna say well isn't that
dangerous don't they hey Westerners
other people might tell you you'll be
beheaded they're all terrorists blah
blah blah and so unfortunately this is
what the media does to us all
it creates our worldviews and there are
other narratives and so that's what my
series shows is the other narrative of
Saudi Arabia so you'll get all sorts of
advice from people that don't know
anything about the country telling you
not to go and it's almost as silly as
getting advice from say a waitress about
brain surgery and because that's not her
profession and so if you want the best
advice on brain surgery you would talk
to you someone that's experienced in
that does it for a profession that lives
in that world and so I'm not saying I'm
the brain surgeon of Saudi Arabia but
there I have experience to talk to those
that have experience do your research on
your own check out different videos and
come up with your own conclusions and I
can only speak from my experience there
which was overall excellent I had two
weeks there it was a big eye-opener I
learned a ton Wow it was it was one of
the coolest trips I've ever taken so
here's some practical advice for you
I'll just take deal with the basics here
first visas super easy online took me
like ten minutes
I think I got the visa that day in my
email you print it off and when you
check through immigrations easy breeze
no problems they're out of the airport
uber took a goober into my hotel in
Riyadh hotels there look the country is
not set up for tourism it hasn't had
many tourists so there are many business
travels there many expats or foreigners
living there but as far as being a
traveler well there are a lot of
travelers from Mecca and Medina and the
religious sites but say being a Western
traveler who is not allowed to go until
just recently
well hotels $50 will get you something
pretty good not great fifty sixty
dollars on the budget front you can do
couchsurfing they do do couchsurfing
that's free so if you want to go super
cheap that's the way to go but as far as
like backpacker hostels I think that
sure will develop there's not so much of
it now and then you can get all the real
expensive hotels if you want
infrastructures good in the country so
getting around on the highways or flying
is excellent and you do have to do those
things it's a big country look at a map
and see like you know measure it on
Google with your fingers and then
compare it to where you're from and see
the distances because Riyadh to Jeddah
is quite a ways
I think I'm roughly eight or nine hour
drive and so everything's really spread
out and often there's a lot of desert
routine so you're gonna want to fly the
inner country flights work really well
they're quite cheap I used this is no
plug they're not giving me anything but
I used Skyscanner
found that to work quite well and then
renting a car in the southwest corner
geez on this is the Saudi Arabia I did
not expect because it was very green and
lush by the way guys this is not Saudi
Arabia this is the Canary Islands in
Spain I left weeks ago but it's a nice
quiet setting to make a video so
southwest corner geez on you want a car
because distances are big you'll want to
cruise around the nature is beautiful
it's actually green with mountains
striking landscapes and when you rent a
car this is something very useful you
want to know that I think most contracts
are like you have to you can only do 200
kilometres a day you can pay a little
bit more and get unlimited miles I
recommend doing that because you never
know what road you're gonna turn down or
you're gonna end up so definitely make
sure you know that you're getting
unlimited miles if that's what you want
food excellent really good food
it's regionalised just like the country
itself like every region is much
different you can't really put one
identity on Saudi like geez on Provence
is totally different than Riyadh totally
different than Jeddah and this is all I
really saw I didn't canvass the whole
country
and I know the Northeast is much
different in the Northwest is much
different so you're dealing with a place
with huge distances and huge regional
differences and so it is a conservative
country for sure but you can't just
label it like so because Jetta for
example is much more open it's a port
city forever
different people have been coming and
going and so that's left its mark it's
got a debt much different vibe than say
Riyadh which is on the in the interior
which feels more conservative and so you
have everything from woman covering full
covers as you'd imagine to woman with no
cover and that is something I didn't
know about and that is something that is
really I'd say overexposed in the West
that whole topic as in most women and
Saudi are prisoners and they're all kept
under cover and super complicated it's a
complicated country I met a woman in a
niqab that chooses to wear it and it's
not because of her family it's not
because of her religious because she
wants to and then I'm sure there are
women that don't want to and then there
there's everything and so again it's
been overexposed in Western media and I
feel a little bit silly honestly at this
point how little I knew about this and
actually how little I knew about Saudi I
think Saudi is one of the most actually
I think it's the most misunderstood
country in the world
I used to say Iran was because I've
gotten Iran a couple times I think Saudi
is the winner now is the most
misunderstood I was a little bit nervous
flying in I'm you know I was like do
they all hate Westerners do they you
know as is it gonna be like super closed
off and I thought it would be because of
well tourism was just opened up recently
but it wasn't
like people are super hospitable like
over-the-top hospitable invite you into
their homes invite you to eat with them
give you presents so it's a country that
in that respect is super easy to travel
and like I showed up at some guy's house
randomly walked up he invited me in gave
me this what I found out later was some
very expensive honey and this is the
treatment I received all over the
country so if you like a culture if you
want to connect with the place if you go
in with an open mind and an open heart
the people will open up fully a very
cool component to it okay what else do I
got here English in the cities the
Saudis speak English quite well that was
surprising I'm in Spain now they speak
way better English and Saudi than Spain
clothes I mean men I you know don't wear
shorts but I think outside of that you
can wear how you you know dress how you
normally dress and women need I don't
know actually I don't want to say the
wrong thing now because things are
changing so quickly sort of depends
where you are I just err on the side of
being respectful I can't imagine it's a
bit hard maybe it is maybe it's not but
for Saudis all the say it was it was
sort of closed off to tourism and now
all these tourism tourists and vloggers
are coming and making all these videos
sort of exposing their perspectives and
their their misunderstandings because
you can't fully understand a place in
two weeks or a month or whatever say all
this information is suddenly bombarded
the internet but be respectful just be
be cool like you're a guest someone
comes to your home you want them to be
respectful you want them not to come in
with muddy boots don't go into Saudi
Arabia with muddy boots metaphorically
speaking go in open-minded understand
that you might not agree with everything
people get really hooked in on the
politics and look most young people like
MBS and why wouldn't they he makes their
lives way better like he's opened up a
lot things have changed so quickly and
so it's basic human nature to like the
person that helps you out makes your
life better and you can be for MBS or
against MBS but don't let that be your
like driving mission of understanding of
the country so yeah just just be
respectful you don't have to agree with
people politically to enjoy them to like
them and who's right and wrong here
anyways I don't know I mean I I think
we're in a ridiculous place in the world
if you know I don't like someone that
likes Trump or I do like someone like
that likes Trump because of that reason
alone I think it's silly that's their
opinion they have their reasons and
again you have a country that is
changing rapidly and drastically and
some people are gonna like those changes
especially the youth and some people are
not going to like this changes a lot of
the more older and conservative people
and that's normal everywhere that's
human like you're stuck in your ways you
don't want to change and changes is the
unknown and it's scary and so this is
the flux Saudi Arabia is in at the
moment it's a very interesting time to
see it and so you'll learn a lot from
the country I learned a lot what they
really offer I would say that the the
world can learn from a lot of the world
can learn from let's say is just this
unbridled hospitality just this is like
genuine openness I also like that it's a
culture that does not revolve around
alcohol like for social time it's not
alcohol is not the center point yeah
that exists people will say it doesn't
and that's what they want it to be but
behind closed doors sorta everything
goes from what I've heard and a little
bit from what I've seen so that exists
but it's not again in open
in public in society you don't see it
and it's it's quite nice I would say
it's quite refreshing and they were just
really connected I think it's something
to learn from the Arab world in general
but I'd say Saudi Arabia is very good at
that is just it's a very connected
culture people are very close to their
families they have strong friend
networks that's what I admire the most
about the culture one thing you might be
surprised with in the beginning
especially as you won't see anyone on
the streets in the day and if you go in
a warm or a hot month which are most of
them they'll be like where are the
people and so it's a nighttime place it
took me a little bit to figure this out
I was like where are the people they
come out at night you know late in the
afternoon the heat kicks down a little
people are hanging out they sleep in
late it seems like let's say the average
person so that should help you a little
bit navigate the place again if you're
thinking you're on the fence of going
and you're worried about your safety
don't really don't be ok anything can
happen anywhere I'm not gonna say
nothing's gonna happen to you but as far
as being in an overtly dangerous place
theft
you know petty crime on the streets is
really low it's one of these countries
that's it's really low and most likely
safer than where you're coming from
ok this path sort of ran out here into
the forest so go go to Saudi Arabia
you'll love it and if you don't love it
love it you'll learn from it and that's
what travel like this is it's like you
can learn about your own country by
being away from it and then you can
learn about a completely different
culture that has things that you admire
so hope that helps have an awesome trip
and yeah check out my series if you want
to see more about Saudi Arabia it's in
the description below okay take care